what has happened in reject nation I'm
Greg Alba and I'm John Humphrey the
experiments achieved from the web camera
back to the t3i baby that's how you do
it sometimes we use the webcam for
longer videos and whatnot live streams
all that fun stuff you know anything if
I you've overcomplicated then you mean
yeah we like to experiment to the public
that's how we do things we're gonna
watch the trailer today the next the
final trailer for a Jackie Chan's the
folder or inner Jackie Chan's Liam
Neeson Death Wish movie she except it's
more believable because it's Jackie Chan
yeah we're like this guy can still
probably still actually do this and
today's patron of the day shad are gonna
go out to none other than my brother
Jeff eco egg that's right he's Jimmy
he's a patron he has some awesome fight
scenes on his channel we'll give you a
full shout out later brother
Caesar Oh soo-young
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's not maintenance people man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Halloween has never looked scary yeah
like I've got a weird slasher movie
where you really understand that are
kind of rooting for this use all those
incredible skills to kill lots of people
you know we said plenty of things on our
last reaction for for this movie one
thing I feel that I really think makes
us stand out a little bit more as a
Jackie Chan taking a different path is
Jackie Chan's been pretty vocal over the
many years he's been doing action films
somehow he's not a fan of guns and he
I've rarely seen him use a gun even in
his honk kong cinema rarely seen him use
it and when he does it's usually for
like it's a violent movie it's like oh
what's his one a Jackie Chan Stu
Parker's into more like a dramatic
territory like I did one movie called
like I think called crime story we're on
the cover he's holding a gun but it's
not like a cool gun action scene you
know you never see Jackie Chan do that
beyond him doing this transition into
more of the dramatic darker territory
that I've been wanting him to go down
they advertised this gunfight on I mean
it's not like just constant guns he's
using but he's really using guns in this
movie well yeah it seems like he's just
skilled in all levels yeah tickle combat
there's AI want to seem that really
struck me where they're in the the comes
as the maintenance man and they have
that old gun fight and that exact that
one moment where he's like whips around
the wall and he's got that look on his
face like I think that was one of the
first moments I really got excited yeah
this trap I like this trailer more in a
way cuz this trailer hit me harder you
made me forget about you know some of
the stuff that concerns me about just
the kind of movie that it is and it got
me focusing on like ah we get to watch
Jackie Chan seriously kick some asses
again
we're in a day and age where a lot of
actors will do or like return or action
stars will do these like older hero
action roles but I think the best
comparison is Liam Neeson in a way
because a lot of times he's like Bruce
Willis return to die hard or Stallone
will return to Rambo or Armel return to
Terminator or every action star
returning the expended yeah but what
Jackie Chan you know I feel like in
America it's rare where we got to see
his strong dramatic acting chops for
Hong Kong he's really known to be a
strong dramatic actor the reason I say
Liam Neeson is because Liam Neeson it
was this really strong dramatic actor
who had this action role turn and taken
and I feel like this could have a little
bit of a different effect for Jackie
Chan look like you could almost bring
him back in give him a second wind in
his career yeah if it does well yeah
because this role will I think will
showcase his dramatic acting chops like
I'm expecting the Rotten Tomatoes
consensus to be like great action scenes
intense with a powerful performance by
Jackie Chan like oh that's what I'm
expecting it to say because I feel like
The Karate Kid really showed America
like this guy can really do drama beyond
me because we all know Jackie Chan's
it's really funny comedic action stars
they're lovable yeah but here I'm like I
feel like what people might walk away
from more because we all know he can
kick ass and we all might be sitting
there to go in like oh yeah he's an old
guy who can kick ass it's great but I
feel like what's really gonna impress
people is I really bought him in this
super dark
role yeah it's been a long time since
he's had a hit here like I haven't seen
a Jackie Chan movie in a while and I
know like skiptrace came out not long
ago but yeah that was actually one of
his better performing films in Hong Kong
really yeah
Johnny Knoxville movie yeah
really opening anomic oh yeah but in
rarity I feel like yeah this this could
be the the sort of second wind to bring
him back and get him in tomorrow because
we love this when this happens like we
love when it works out when you know an
actor we used to love comes back with
you know a bit of a darker heavier
perform right and you know proves they
can still do it night I've missed Jackie
Chan I'm Jackie Chan I hope this can
open up I don't want this to be like
every kind of movie he makes in America
from now on but I do hope this opens the
door back up to you know us having
ejected Chan around and more than just
animated movie boys and I'm hoping if
this movie is a hit that he doesn't just
immediately go back to what we've seen
of Jackie Chan - I'm the same spectrum I
don't want it to only be these kind of
roles but I also don't want him to like
Eddie Murphy himself yeah yeah it's like
do Dreamgirls and in Norbit
don't do that no I hope he can do you a
kind of a range of things moving forward
from this because for the longest time
he was said he wanted to be like a
Robert DeNiro but no one can ever buy
him is that in America I hope this movie
does actually play some of that stuff up
and get into the the character you know
for real because I don't know from this
trailer how much that's gonna happen and
I know they show you know they do the
lack of like intense close-ups of him
looking really depressed there are a
couple shots of this where I like wow it
looks like these is a pagina when they
depressed yeah yeah there's a potential
here for you know a powerful character
performance from Jackie Chan - now that
I'm expecting it to be like a character
study movie but I hope that this helps
remind us not only yeah like you said
that you can kick ass but also of his
acting job yeah and you know opens the
door back up from there you know before
the studio is done patron the day shout
out for my brother jab eco a shabby
Gebbie I want you to know that if we
ever fought I know used to beat me up
all the time when I was younger when we
did Taekwondo together but I want you to
know now
I'd still lose badly I would definitely
lose to both of you though so I feel
like you know I'm gonna if you ever
fought me I'm gonna hire jab me to
protect me
in actuality my brother comes across as
tough and strong really he's a [ __ ]
what you should do to find out what I
mean by that is check out his raging
bullish black and white short film he
did that's right you can see it'll kill
real javi in that short film link in the
description box subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell -
on Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram and
you can go check out our patreon become
a patron eject today